der hält was jedoch und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja ich
hoffe natürlich euch jetzt gut ich bin
da ein bisschen außer puste ich musste
noch pakete schleppen aber darum geht's
weiter auf back to business
wir können es wir machen heute wieder
ein sehr geiles unboxing-video ich freue
mich sehr das war meine idee und zwar
dachte ich mir ich vergleiche einfach
mal 1 250 euro paket von saturn mit
einem 250 euro paket von media markt
gleich viel wie macht beides ist mit
mindestens doppeltem waren wir das war
ganz groß deklariert in den anzeigen und
dann schauen wir einfach mal welches
besser ist ich weiß ich habe euch auch
noch das 10.000 euro paket versprochen
das wird auch noch kommen gibt's moral
nicht bevor wir das jetzt allerdings
machen muss ich einmal noch zwei
gewünscht wieder auflösen einmal geht es
um die lumix cam und dann noch ein
personen nicht personalisierte aber
einen restposten paket von mir hier wird
jetzt einmal der gewinner der kamera
eingeblendet
herzlichen glückwunsch an dich ich werde
mich bei ihm melden sonst kannst du dich
auch bei mir melden und dann hier noch
der gewinner von restposten paket dann
haben wir das jetzt auch mal aus der
welt geschafft aber ich denke wir werden
heute auch der irgendwas rausholen so
wie immer das oder muss ich ja irgendwie
auch machen ich würde sagen ich zeige
euch erstmal die pakete und dann schauen
wir mal
hier haben wir zunächst mal das
rettungspaket das ist wirklich eher
klein aber auch nicht schwer wiegt ein
kilo
das werde ich mal hier hin und dann
jetzt auch das medienpaket das bisschen
größer und das wird dann auch schon mal
also zehn kilo deswegen ihr könnt schon
sehen zwei unterschieden großes paket
für 250 euro
kleines paket 1450 euro er verstehe ich
habe mir gedacht ich mache das einfach
mal so beziehen immer abwechselnd dann
wird hier einmal auf dieser seite der
wert für die saturn box americans und
hier dann meinetwegen in rot der wert
für die mediabox mal schauen wer am ende
gewinnt wer kann das battle nach hause
holen ich muss sagen ich bin eher auf
der seite von saturn
weil die pathetisch sondern vom strich
glaube ich immer ein bisschen besser
waren aber wer weiß okay ich bin
gespannt wir fangen einfach mal mit
saturn an hier deswegen man schnell zur
seite ich gucke gar nicht drauf netz
glaube das geht auf jeden fall wieder
sehr überschaubar los wir starten wir
hier also wir hatten hier auf dem 3000
euro paket einen dreisten luftreiniger
hier aber den dyson war da wird meine
freunde jetzt durch drehen hier bei
diesen dingen das ist gleichen korrekt
keine ahnung ich habe so ein ding vorher
noch nie benutzt aber für die mädels ist
dass der wasser
deswegen hier direktwahl der wert dafür
ich denke das kostet mindestens 200 300
euro doch alter krass das ist schon sehr
bild hier noch mal für euch so sieht das
auf jeden fall schon mal eine krasse
anlage von saturn
wir machen mal mit megawatt steigern
hier haben wir ein techno mehrtages
vorhersage punkt wetterstation
dankeschön
also das ist auch gar nicht mal so
schlecht aber der erste von geht auf den
fall an saturn das ding ist halt nur in
dieser stunde sind leider gottes vier
artikeln
ok weiter geht's von saturn haben wir
das belkin weile starting at okay so
sieht das ganze aus wird nicht teuer
sein auf dieser preis zeichnet kein plan
weiter geht's mit media alles klar eine
action cam von wohl auch nicht schlecht
wobei ich weiß die dinger sind nicht so
teuer
das ist er so dieses gopro von gestellt
wir schätzen das kostet 30 40 euro
aber besser als nix 42 tastaturen oder
nein das hatte ich ja schon mal irgendwo
drin
das ist ein rentner handy von ok
mobiflip für ich glaube das kostet 30
euro fiel das auf jeden fall mit ich
hoffe da ist doch irgendwas drin womit
man was anfangen
dann eine media markt düsseldorf weg ich
habe das hier bestellt vom mediamarkt
düsseldorf dass ihr kommt vom saturn wie
ist das denn nochmal saturn norderstedt
also wenn das in eurer nähe ist lassmann
schönen gruß famila danke für diesen
wunderschönen beutel kann ich auf jeden
fall eigentlich immer was mit anfangen
dann machen wir weiter mit der nächsten
power band ganz ehrlich was wäre so eine
wundertüte
ohne power bank es muss ja immer drin
sein wird zwar auch nicht viel kosten
also der typ für die gepackt hat war auf
jeden fall
na ja ich würde mal sagen eher faul aber
er hat gegen diesen fetten dyson corail
und dann halt doch quatsch reisen.de km
verbraucht die haben wir ein wort mit
trading cards ein sammelordner ohne
scheiß wenn ich das so ihr euch zeige es
war bis jetzt jedes mal so wir haben es
safe 20er jüngere war inter geschrieben
alex bürger kannst du mir bitte geben
vom fortnight kostet nur 99 später auch
drauf also bis jetzt ich bin gespannt
was da noch kommt da muss noch was
kommen
wir sind bei saturn jetzt hier leider
dann schon durch mit denen habe ich noch
nie gehört die marke auf jeden fall
haben wir hier kannst du deinen arsch
stecken musiker ist in ordnung also wenn
ich das hochrechnet wir haben jetzt so
genau 500 euro als wert der wert für
diese tolle sachen seht ihr hier schon
eingesammelt
ich denke das wird ein enges rennen also
das muss ich media markt lassen da diese
box ist von unten bis oben hin voll
gepackt mit irgendeinem schritt wir
haben hier zb von tassimo krämer
entkoffeinierten was soll ich damit
irgendwelche kaffeepads aber was soll
ich mit diesem patch wenn ich nicht auch
gleich die passende kaffeemaschine
zu haben und die sieht so aus die freude
seht ihr mein gesicht hält sich eher in
grenzen weil diese dinge gibt es glaube
ich schon für 30 euro internet ich weiß
gar nicht wo da die 500 euro herkommen
sollen
da muss ja noch irgendwas geiles drin
sein dann haben wir hier das thema latte
macchiato okay nicht schlecht eigentlich
kann ich sogar diese kaffeemaschine wir
behalten und in meinem büro stellen das
mache ich auch weil ich brauche hier
einfach eine und bis jetzt habe ich noch
keine bestellt und wenn die leckeren
kaffee macht was willst du mehr
noch mehr kompetenz und noch mehr und
noch mehr also die trinken auf jeden
fall im mediamarkt düsseldorf extrem
gerne kaffee weiter geht's mit spiele
seien über 100 spielmöglichkeiten
hier wird der preis direkt schon
mitgeliefert 16 eur 48 hat das im laden
und gekostet und jetzt haben wir hier
noch greifbar wie zum beispiel natürlich
das muss ja auch irgendwie mit rein
diese atemschutzmasken pp2 so viele
masken managerin irgendwelchen paketen
hatte können hier auch massen shop auch
machen dann haben wir hier noch einen
displayport adapter für hdmi ok sims 4 1
60 eur 99 kostet das man muss ja auch
sagen das ist schon ein relativ beliebt
das spiel deswegen gar nicht so schlecht
nur trotzdem wenn ich das jetzt grob
überschlagen
hey wir sind noch weit entfernt von 500
euro und das einzige
noch an wert audi kann ich auch da
halten
230 gigabyte mini sd karte kostet so
würde ich mal schätzen zwar halte ich
aber auf jeden fall kann ich immer
gebrauchen
und jetzt haben wir hier von mascha die
monitore to active noise cancelling
kopfhörer
ich weiß dass sie nicht günstig sind ich
habe keinen plan eigentlich müssen die
jetzt auch so 3 oder 4 100 euro kosten
damit ich hier diesen 500 euro wert
erreicht weil sonst wird's eng
ohne scheiß ich bin mir sicher wir 500
euro safe nicht erreicht die kosten 196
euro 99 im laden alles natürlich neue
produkte
ihr seht das jetzt schon ich habe keine
ahnung aber ich denke der punkt geht auf
jeden fall an saturn das ist dass das
rechte paket war wie auch schon erwartet
okay wir haben hier noch eine smart
watch mit bei sind auch nicht die kosten
und sonst noch so cds oder ich muss
sagen leute ich bin etwas enttäuscht von
der media markt cox glaube ich na ja ich
würde sagen ich rechne mal zusammen ist
dann meine live action da drauf und es
gleich okay leute ich hab mal ein
bisschen kopfrechnen gemacht und haare
folgendes ermitteln können saturn hat
obwohl eventuell gewonnen der rechte
mann zusammen insgesamt bin ich bei
mediamarkt auf einen gesamtwert von 425
euro gekommen was an sich schon nicht so
leistet weil im angebot steht halt
wirklich mindestens 500 euro
und das sind alles die preise von media
markt und da komme ich halt nicht auf
500 euro
na ja das ist natürlich ein bisschen
doof aber noch saturn und da will ich
insgesamt 570 euro und kommt also 50
euro mehr als mindestens war korrekt von
euch vor allem dieses gleichen teil
kostet 450 euro was geisteskrank ist
allein damit habe ich ja schon 200 euro
plus gemacht
saturn hat ganz klar gewonnen mit 145
euro abstand einige sachen findet ihr
wie immer jetzt auf kino.de meinem job
da gibt es auch noch andere coole sachen
ich habe da echt
so viel zu tun deswegen es lohnt sich da
immer mal reinzuschauen ach so und das
muss doch irgendwas raushauen habe
gesprochen ich kann euch leider heute
nichts anbieten außer ein neues
restposten paket da habe ich noch einige
von deswegen aber die werden echt ganz
cool so schreibt netten kommentar wir
sehen uns eventuell sonntag wieder
gibt's neues video abonniert super super
gerne würde ich mich sehr darüber freuen
und yahoo drei leute